moment in the limelight you know because
uh you know there's nothing wrong with
dreaming big there's nothing wrong with
having these big aspirations and in
chess it's so important to be confident
he has to believe in his abilities
especially if he's going to match the
world champion the only thing that i
would say is he needs to be a little bit
careful and just spot those tactical
moments
okay and uh we start with the reti
opening white developing the night out
first and then just pushing the pawn
next to it to create a nice safe space
for the white bishop to fianchetto
itself on a long diagonal so we've seen
this before from magnus actually i think
two or three times already this
tournament yeah and uh hans surely he
won't be too surprised uh black
occupying the center with pawns white
meanwhile staying a bit more flexible
just getting the white king castled
usually first before deciding what pawns
to push in the center uh are you
surprised do you anchor that hans is
even thinking at this point at this
moment
um
not
yes i am surprised that he's thinking
actually because uh like you said magnus
has actually played this before i mean
primarily i'm thinking of his game
against uh young christopher doodle in
the first round um but having said that
said that magnus has actually been
playing more of the king's pawn forward
this tournament so maybe
he's just uh having a pause and
considering what to do so he decides
instead to
develop his dark squared bishop yep so
this is all very well known territory
and actually complete symmetry right now
the players kind of copying each other
white is the first to castle most likely
black will do the same there we go
complete symmetry uh this is one of the
most frustrating things in chess when
your opponent copies exactly what you do
i remember when i was first starting
to play my opponents would just do this
and
it just confused me it got in my mind
but magnus has had this position before
in this tournament against jordan van
furiste exactly yeah
so he knows what's going on here magnus
actually offers a pawn sacrifice it's
kind of the queen's gambit but delayed
and the gambit wasn't accepted black
didn't capture a pawn and now everything
protected for white white has a small
space advantage because he has two pawns
on the fourth rank and black is mainly
trying to just build a solid wall
himself and han's just looking off to
the left there he's trying to remember
what he's analyzed uh for sure this
position isn't new to him he's probably
studied three or four different plans
for black and he's just trying to pick
between them okay in the end he brings
his bishop out
and uh we'll see the moves continue to
be played fast this is still a very well
known uh kind of theoretical position
so white's fiend cutted both of the
bishops i like the setup just because
the white bishop will come to life later
on
meanwhile hans okay pushing this pawn
with one square
that's quite rare that is rare i mean
only three games in my particular
database um it is it is kind of a little
bit of a normal strategy though to kind
of take control of the light squares and
just prepare to push the b pawn two
squares forward and try to force white
to determine uh the pawn tension
so most likely white uh black sorry will
put all the pawns on light squares
and uh okay white bringing the night out
meanwhile very sensible by magnus and
black also developing and yeah later on
black will just build a wall maybe every
single pawn will be on a light square
and it's just gonna be hard for magnus
to break through uh that barrier so um
yeah if you notice all of black's pawns
right now apart from one it's on a light
square i'm pretty sure huns will try and
play that move at some point later
yeah having said that you know it just
reminds me of uh
something that happened with my one of
my team captains when i was playing in
the european team championship or the
olympiad they would joke
oh yavi you've been her light square
strategy she's all her horns on that
square and i'm like oh yeah it's true i
do
i would like all of your openings all of
them involve putting my pawns on light
squares really yeah
i don't know how it worked out that way
but it did
and i can recommend it
yeah there's different types of openings
for example the slav defense or the
queen's gun bit declined you put all
your pawns on light squares there are
other openings where you put all your
pawns on dart squares like the king's
indian the old indian there's lots of
different
and is it a good idea to
so say you want to use maybe three
different kind of openings
to use the ones that actually put the
pieces on the same color is it you know
some pattern recognition something you
can get out of it yeah you definitely
can like for instance when i whenever i
faced against the queen's pawn opening
i've always put my pawns on light
squares and the same goes if i space
against the king's pawn opening and i
can at an occasion interchange those uh
plans that accompany the pawn structure
yeah it's just
i think it's just somehow a little bit
strange and it just means that i can
also play other openings that involve
putting my pawns yes light squares and
often when you start with the black
pieces the main goal is just surviving
the opening
in order to win with black you first
have to equalize the position and then
you look for small imbalances and then
you try and play for a win later in the
game so
in order to just survive the opening it
is quite a good strategy to put a pawn
in the center back it up with other
pawns and that's what hans is doing
right now so he's just trying to
equalize the position according to the
evaluation bar he's done that and now we
just uh reach a middle game where it's
all about maneuvering still every single
pawn every single piece on the board and
it's about who can put their pieces on
better squares who can activate who can
go for pawn exchanges peace exchanges at
the right moment
and uh the game will take a bit of a
slower turn for the next few moves uh
while maybe hans comes up with a plan
while the players debate which pieces to
move where to put them but uh after that
as we saw in magnus's game against
jordan things do tend to explode a bit
later in the middle game still very
early stages and very tense right yeah
i have to say i was a little bit
surprised by hans developing his
knight because i actually expected the
knight to jump into the center
and the reason why i would expect the
knight to jump into the center and offer
itself up for trade is because if you
look at black's position it's somehow a
little cramped and there's this little
thing that when you're suffering in
terms of space you try to swap off minor
pieces and the expression that that i've
heard and i use and actually comes from
jessie cray and it says you send your
children to boarding school
too many occupants in the house so you
send the kids off to school and uh just
makes life easier
so one idea
is your one ivanka yeah trade off a set
of knights and actually space tends not
to be an issue in any type of pawn
structure once you've exchanged one set
of minor pieces knights or bishops
so black's pieces if you look at the
black knights previously they were just
fighting for the same squares now that's
no longer the case they're not in each
other's way
we call them superfluous knights one is
often just useless if it can't occupy
the square it wants to use if it's
fellow knight is actually sitting on
that square so um if your knights are in
the way of each other swap one night off
the other night becomes much happier
what was the word su superfluous it
means
i always forget
yeah or useless night so perfectly is
nights yeah it's a complicated word and
i always forget it you know it's not one
that rolls off the tongue but uh yeah
it's a good word to know
you can be impressed if i ever ask you
oh david is this a superfluous night i
look forward
and meanwhile just the last move both
sides bring their rooks to the c file
just in anticipation of things opening
up
still it feels like both sides are kind
of tip-toeing around a bit scared to
initiate
any real trades any real action but uh
the moment will come and yeah we'll keep
updated with that typical first game in
the knockout match yeah everyone's a bit
cagey you don't quite know how it's
going to go so you kind of just play a
little bit slowly and wait for the
action to stop brewing at a later stage
and talking about action and
entertainment we still want everyone at
home to be enthusiastic and excited
about the chess and we very much want
you at home to be part of this
experience so please tweet us your
thoughts your move suggestions even your
selfies we really love those remember to
take them in landscape mode and you can
do all this by tweeting us using the
hashtag chess champs i'm really
interested to see where people are
following the chess now obviously time
of day is very different for our viewers
someone is it's at night someone is you
know working hours
are you watching at school your job are
you sitting at home are you home
officing
because of course you know covet is
slowly going away so maybe people are
starting to go back to the office and
watching with some colleagues but
hopefully they're not watching at school
because that would be a little bit
naughty
and we don't advocate to her bunking off
for some lessons to watch our show but
we won't tell the teacher
that is unless we read out that tweet
and their teacher is also in the staff
room
i want to know who people are supporting
as well because i know hans oh yeah it's
a huge online following he was a
streamer for many years uh in the us
he's very very popular of course
releasing courses doing lots of things
these days and uh okay magnus army of
fans himself so they're just shuffling
his queen to a slightly better square
more importantly though it's not where
the queen is placed it's the fact that
the white rooks are connected and when
your rooks are connected they become
much more flexible later you can
actually stack them up on the same line
for example white might try and double
his rooks on the c file or white's other
rook will come the one next to his king
it will come to the center to the square
the white queen previously sat on
because if things do open up rooks in
the middle of the board are far stronger
than if they sit on their kind of home
squares so um still very cagey just
dancing around each other and at the at
this moment it feels like hans maybe
will initiate this nitrate because he's
running out of other moves
the black queen can come out on her
diagonal okay he backs up his knight and
here we have the old superfluous knight
kyle
[Laughter]
take a look at that knight sitting
blocking in the dark squared bishop it
wants to jump into the center but lo and
behold its sibling is standing there so
that's why it's called superb last night
yeah they both want to use this square
but only one knight can occupy that
square
at the right time so um yeah his idea is
to actually get rid of one of them for
example if magnus moves the rook as we
expected just lining his rooks up on
central uh files okay instead he's moved
his knight into the center but i'm
pretty sure hans needs to get rid of one
of these two nights now they're just in
each other's way so trade one of them
off there we go it happens he's going to
take this one off and then replace it in
the center with his other knight and
those super superfluous knights have
been separated now and uh and he still
has a night on that great square exactly
it's not quite an outpost it might get
kicked away later by a pawn but uh first
you were attacking this bishop so the
bishop steps back and hans if he wants
can actually evict the white knight from
the center as well with a pawn push um
you've got to weigh up the pros and cons
you might kick away this white knight
but
suddenly after the white knight retreats
your bishop will be blocked in behind a
pawn so
pros and cons you've got to weigh that
up and you also gotta weigh up when
the black knight steps back because it
will have to at some point due to
white's pawn push and okay hans
meanwhile he's going for it he's
bringing his queen out some vague
threats now capturing a pawn you don't
want to get your queen trapped of course
you've got to be very careful that pawn
isn't poisoned but at least he's
creating threats he's forcing the world
champion to go onto the back foot and
the evaluation bar shooting up in
white's favor
it's not clear why but i don't like it
uh sorry you don't like blacksmith i
don't like
blacks move at all
i'm thinking that uh you know maybe kick
back the night and uh you know my
favorite plan
basically when the night moves say say
moves back okay well operation kickback
continues and i'm going to kick you back
one more time
how do you make at this point push no i
was going to kick back the knight i was
going i was going to kick you there and
then
and then yeah once you even move
backwards and then i'm thinking you know
hey let's uh let's begin let's maybe
push the a3 pawn they to pawn you can
maybe even kick back the black queen
with your bishop the black queen steps
back you kick back the black bishop
exactly bishop steps back and suddenly
we talked about being cramped look at
black's pieces they're really
suffocating here struggling for air
struggling for space and uh yeah that
operation has begun actually you're
right ivanka everything comes with tempo
in chess we talk about tempo it means
you force a move you gain time on every
turn first you kick back the night the
night steps back maybe it won't go the
direction i mentioned because of your
idea but if it does step back here which
it wants to it wants to use the square
then suddenly you gain another tempo
forcing the opponent's reply having to
go back you gain another tempo forcing
the opponent's reply they have to go
back and again once more
gaining all the time in the world every
piece coming with a threat every move
coming with a threat and yeah in this
position maybe han's just missing the
moment he wants to come and take this
pawn but just no time to do that
and uh yeah first
of all your knight is under attack and
not too many safe squares i don't think
you can jump into the position you want
to of course protected by your queen but
this knight just gets trapped and for
example this is a double attack hitting
the black queen hitting the black knight
as well
so you have to go back and if you have
to go back it's a bad sign you've lost
time so yeah magnus really
kind of sensing the moment and starting
operation kickback and it's a very
familiar plan to magnus i've seen him do
it many times
i remember seeing him do it to janna
pomnyashi in norway chess in their
playoff match
and i had had a word with magnus
afterwards and i was like why why did
why didn't the promise allow that and he
said yeah it was a bit strange wasn't it
so i was very proud of myself when i
spotted this that i was on the same
wavelength as the world champion
yeah and uh
yes very standard it's very natural as
well and i think hans now the reason
he's been thinking for two minutes is
he's realized he's in
maybe not massive trouble he's not
losing or anything but he's really gonna
have to start just retreating everything
and going back to square one and uh okay
he goes back in this direction so at
least he doesn't lose time having to
retreat his knight again after any pawn
pushes but i'm expecting magnus to start
either hitting that black light square
bishop as we showed with the pawn or
maybe even driving back the black queen
with white's dark square bishop yeah i i
like attacking the queen you know the
queen is doing nothing there you might
as well get a free move and then again
you still have the plan of operation
expansion with the pawns so
uh i really do think that uh
where did i get that from oh
yeah i know hans niemann is struggling a
little bit too too cramped yeah maybe
they i mean they both begin with n right
nema nepogi
yeah uh to my too many things going on
in my brain and uh whilst uh magnus is
pondering whether to initiate operation
kickback or not i do want to share with
you some selfies that we've already got
oh wow oh well we wait one second
there is kickback but it is a central
expansion yeah that's greedy gaining all
the space pushing a pawn hitting black's
bishop and the black bishop had to
retreat you notice in the center there's
some tension between some pawns but
every white pawn is protected by another
pawn so white has this kind of nice
formation all of white's pawns if you
notice they're pointing towards the
center black doesn't want to trade
anything off because that would only
help open up white's pieces and uh
magnus there after the black bishop
retreated dropping back his knight
and i'm trying to work out whether
black can be super greedy here the black
queen sitting on the side of the board
she could go and grab a pawn but it
feels like that is
almost suicidal it feels like the black
queen would get trapped if that happens
it does look like that right we have to
jump in because this is actually a pawn
sacrifice by the world champion we
showed that this pawn push attacking the
black bishop drove the bishop back and a
really subtle retreat so white's knight
now is actually quite flexible on this
square
it's a dream square in a lot of queens
pawn openings he wants to go this way
maybe to take the bishop he wants to go
maybe this way forward and to capture
the bishop and if as mentioned black
takes this pawn which i would be very
tempted to do because i'd be scared of
the position anyway as black you might
as well have something to suffer for but
i think magnus's idea is possibly to
jump forward with his knight to this
square and uh now not only do you attack
this bishop not only do you attack this
pawn but you also threaten to trap this
black queen and uh yeah the reason you
couldn't trap this black queen on the
previous move is because the queen can
actually capture this pawn this is the
only escape route so you might as well
bring your knight forward first to
defend this square but meanwhile hans he
didn't
pluck up the courage to play that move
that would have been extremely risky
instead he brings his bishop to the side
of the board attacking the white rook
and the white rook can move of course uh
it ideally wants to keep this pawn under
protection but uh okay hans at least
trying to disrupt white's piece
coordination the threat is this rook of
course and still magnus has to calculate
what happens on the next turn if black
does go and grab this loose pawn in the
corner it's done to heat up definitely
and it feels good for white just because
white occupies the center white's pieces
are more centralized but still a bit of
hard work to do for magnus to prove that
that actually is meaningful yeah
i mean it's here's the kind of candidate
moves that you would look at is like
step forward with the rook that would be
something that maybe is a little bit of
a no-brainer just on the basis that you
can use the analysis that we worked out
from the move before another one move
would be like it actually maybe stepping
forward with the knights to attack the
bishop
and uh just saying hey let's uh
you've weakened your king a little bit
let's start looking at some pieces so
those are the kind of main moves i would
be looking at yeah and we could see a
really cool pawn structure here if black
actually captures this knight so white
will have doubled pawns but just look
how strong these four are right now we
talk about controlling center these four
pawns together just uh super powerful so
uh that could have happened but magnus
actually it might still happen magnus
instead flicking in a different move
what we call an intermezzo or vision
zook like an in-between move before
dealing with a threat against his rook
he counters against the black queen so a
counter threat and attacking the queen
of course and most importantly defending
this pawn now in the corner the black
queen has to retreat
yeah i'm trying to make a point of it
i'm not using an engine until i really
really need it and i'm trying to make a
point of like cct checks captures
threats
and uh yeah forgot about this one tour
oh my god
yeah how did that never ever occur to me
did it ever occur to you cct
checks captures threats champions chess
tour absolutely chess player 101 the
first thing you learned the first thing
you have to remind yourself every move
on every game cct it's a match made in
heaven i know champions chess tour
never have to think about remember
anything again just champions chester
checks capture threats exactly
gosh
what a moment you guys ah yeah it really
feels like that eureka moment there you
just told me i was like oh my goodness
me never ever occurred to me and uh hans
stepping back with his queen
very unfortunate move but okay it had to
be done yeah going back the whole way
oh to me it looks a bit weird it just
looks like a lot of time uh black's
queen of course came from this square
what was it four or five moves ago it
came out and then it had to go back to
me i would have maybe stepped to a
different diagonal just to provoke uh
maybe white to push some pawns but uh
okay hans just playing the safe option
and at least the black queen won't get
hit anymore white won't gain any more
time against her the magnus has played
quite fast so far um the other matches
are of course uh going on as well and i
did see the bar actually all the way
over to liam leia's side in his first
game today against david navarra and now
all of these matches will contain of
four rapid games and when they finish a
game they have 15 minutes no matter what
happens in the other matches 15 minutes
and then they start the next game so
we're gonna have chess going on
all the time today it's going to be
super fun yeah
and whilst magnus is pondering finally i
can share with you the selfies so abby
scheck says uh my buddy ninu isn't very
friendly with me can a game of chess
help improve the relationship and uh
there he is very cool yellow room and
there's a little budgie there what's a
budgie a budgie is a bird it's a badgery
girl uh it's a small little bird very
cute
i used to have one as a pet a long time
ago really yeah but it died obviously
hello first and last time his name was
pedro
and hague says me and magnus
oh
that's a good way to spend the day hey
it definitely is and keep those selfies
keep those questions and those comments
coming and you can do that by tweeting
us using the hashtag chesschamps we will
try and feature them on the show did you
have any pets when you were a kid david
no unfortunately not my mother was
afraid of all animals so
uh maybe one day maybe one day what
would you what would you have if you
i always envisioned myself with a tiny
little cute dog oh
like a chihuahua yeah he could be my
wingman when i'm out on the street
i wanted to tortoise at some point in my
life yeah i even had the name picked out
lola lola the tortoise it's like amazing
but i heard the tortures they will
outlive
yeah this is i didn't think it through
it was only until my husband said hey
you you are prepared to be in it for the
long haul yeah
yeah maybe that was a bit of a
commitment so i said no
okay and actually quite a big moment in
the game so magnus got his rook out of
the eyeline of the black dark squad
bishop that rook was under fire and uh
now also lining itself up with the black
queen if you look on the central file on
the d file really good strategy
it just makes the opponent feel
uncomfortable if their queen is being
stared at by a rook even if there's some
stuff in the way at the moment when the
position opens
the tactics will work now in white's
favor and
black can actually grab a pawn but i
don't think he should hans okay he
doesn't grab
uh any of the white pawns in the center
because that would have allowed white's
knight to jump forward and that would
have been really scary for black so hans
now with these pawn pushers especially
his last pawn push he has limited the
action the activity of the white knight
so i think that last move was very very
important and uh that was nice from the
teenager just controlling the position
he's still struggling purely because
he's lacking space and white's central
pawns are so strong but at least he's
not losing immediately he's not facing
any immediate uh kind of setbacks
i think sometimes in chess even if
you've got a worse position even if
you've got a disadvantage you need to
take the time out just to stabilize and
survive for a few moves because this is
the type of advantage for magnus which
may or may not disappear over the next
three or four moves it's nothing
immediate it's nothing material and look
at this magnus already starting to
retreat with his knight yeah i think
he's doing it for concrete reason right
because uh he wants to control the g4
square
just in case
hands wanted to exchange the the king's
pawn in the center okay so we can show
this and
i'm surprised i must admit it wasn't
even on my radar but uh as you mentioned
if magnus had just pushed pawns this is
a very magnus type of move gaining space
getting ready for the end game to push
pawns further up the board then one idea
that you mentioned ivanka is to actually
start initiating those trades taking
pawns and then starting to bring the
bishop across hitting the white queen
hitting the rook behind it and suddenly
some quick moves the white knights drop
back covering that key square and hans
decided now is the moment and
oh to me it feels like the wrong moment
but possibly uh he just couldn't wait
any longer he did initiate some trades
and it's all about these pawns now
there's a threat of bishop takes pawn
hitting the white queen and the rook
behind it using the black bishop but the
question is can white advance can white
step forward with this guy or this guy
hans thinks no that is the acid test
right i mean can we try it
out on the board yeah i think the key
move here is whether this pawn push
works just trying to remember
breakthrough using the rook on the same
line as the black queen but after pawn
takes pawn maybe there's an issue for
white because ideally you want to
capture towards the center you don't
want to capture a way
you want to capture this way but
unfortunately bishop is hanging so some
calculation to be done here is still
really complicated
yeah he goes for it
anyhow because there are a lot of
captures in the position actually
um yeah i mean
for instance okay so pawn takes now you
can we have this position that we just
showed on the board so for example now
after rook takes bishop it looks like a
free bishop but after white recaptures
the black bishop there is actually a
double threat uh hitting the black queen
and next move maybe just going to
capture this pawn with a check and i
think this is quite likely to happen
black's queen now can just dodge out the
way i'm not sure which square is best
but uh after a porn trade now it's still
very very tense white's pieces are
actually not as active as they were
previously black does okay this is about
to happen black does have a nice bishop
a nice queen nice rook controlling lots
of squares but white can start pushing
forward again pushing this guy pushing
the spawn next and white's moves all
come with threats
so okay this one feels like black should
be fine somehow but still it feels like
magnus in the driving seat uh just
because he can start pushing and also
white's king is safer than blacks if you
imagine for example white getting just
one more move
pushing forward in the center hitting
the black knight then suddenly white's
bishop is going to be far stronger than
this block of wood on the side of the
board and it's definitely heating up in
all of the other quarterfinal matches as
well look at the bar liam looking good
for him against david nomar in game one
the bar just went all the way over to
duda's side in his game against david
anton and world number three ding the
bar is liking it for him against jordan
fun for his game one bunch of moves
a bunch of moves and very similar to
what we predicted but magnus actually
went for this line without trading a set
of pawns so magnus he's definitely been
influenced by daniel dubov studying with
him because earlier he tried to give up
a couple of pawns it wasn't accepted by
neiman he gave up a couple of pawns
earlier a few moves later it wasn't
taken by hans neiman and finally black
is a pawn up but uh look at this the
kickback has started again black's
knight under threat i get what he's
trying to do
so magnus is playing purely in a
positional way he's just saying look at
black's bishop locked out of the game
i'm going to be a peace up yeah i
mentioned it's basically a block of wood
this bishop and the black bishop the
only way to break out of this cage is to
sacrifice itself at some point
hans here he would love to trade off all
the pieces just to get out his bishop
from behind white's strong pawn chain on
the dart squares here but it's just not
possible
and magnus if he's clever will find a
way of just
keeping this bishop caged while as
ivanka mentions just pretending he's a
piece up uh what black's actually the
pawn up in this position he goes for a
trade slightly surprising maybe that
black knight too strong but
i have the way the white knight better
than the black bishop how impressed are
you now with uh the way hounds has
defended this it didn't look too good
for a while there
well
despite what the computer is saying i
wouldn't say it looks too good for him
now i mean hans has to tread very
accurately because as david mentioned
the bishop not great piece is just
jammed in by white set pawns so white
could so black could be in effect a
piece down if that bishop doesn't get
motoring doesn't fire way way out all
magnus needs to do is start playing in
the center use his extra knight and it
will be such a dreadful position for
hans so he's not out of the woods yet
okay yeah i'm kind of impressed by both
players magnus because he's trying to go
for this long-term kind of domination
she's controlling the black bishop but
hans he did okay wow talking of
bad pieces he's decided that that black
bishop was so bad he sacrificed it he's
given it up for just two pawns and
suddenly the white king is a bit open
but magnus frowning he's surprised that
move
so brave i mean you're a piece down now
and white's knight keeps the king
relatively safe
so hans upping the stakes and i don't
think that was necessary i think he was
just maybe
i mean he's a confident player hans
maybe he's overestimating his chances
here or maybe he just thought there was
nothing better but this was just a last
ditch kind of last resort type of move
and he played it really relatively
quickly
ivanka i mean i'm a materialist i prefer
having the white knight here over the
black pawns what do you think well
actually having sat next to you all this
time i'm like hang on a second
white has the perfect defender
a knight is a king's best friend so i
don't think white is in any danger
whatsoever so
i agree a bit
bit too eager maybe your hands was
panicking a little bit yeah and
i mean his bishop was
not the best piece in the world as we
were saying but i don't think that was
the right moment to sacrifice
there are actually no current threats on
the board no matter what black does next
whites of rooks can block i mean the
white rook next to the king you can even
centralize that double up the white
rooks on the d file maybe even go for
the black king which lacks defenders
and uh yeah a piece for two pawns if all
the queen's rooks disappear
it's just a simple win for white with
the extra knights so
um yeah hans definitely he's playing
against maybe magnus's clock magnus's
nerves
he just wants to find uh that kind of
chaotic position that we were talking
about before the show maybe it was just
his match strategy beforehand just not
allow any
slow quiet kind of maneuvering end games
it's all about chaos and maybe it's just
a practical decision here yeah could
also be part of the magnus effect you're
like well you know i don't want to
suffer he's probably going to torture me
for a long time
so
let's just do it let's take that risk
and unfortunately this can backfire
because as you'll probably find out
magnus is a great defender
yeah that's the thing many players think
uh oh magnus is going to beat me anyway
might as well go down in flames but
sometimes that speeds up their own
defeat
and okay meanwhile white's knight has
centralized itself offering a trade of
rooks as we mentioned trades long term
should help white uh with the material
advantage now but uh at night versus two
pawns it's not
completely over so uh still some fight
left and the evaluation bar still
thinking black has some chances it's not
all one-way traffic yeah
um
i don't one move i don't think that
black should be playing is that trading
rooks
if you trade rooks then it actually
helps white because the queen is quite
nicely placed on next to her king
because
black's king is unsafe as well
promise what else uh where do you run
away from if you don't want to trade off
the set of rooks
okay he does that he does take it the
black rook in order to avoid this trade
would have had to kind of flee to one of
the sides of the board and then this
white rook on the file would have been
really scary pointing towards the black
king so
maybe just yeah i agree you don't want
swap rooks but maybe there was just no
other choice process of elimination so
what do you think will be the result of
this game i mean what looks the most
likely right now to me magnus winning
okay
i agreed uh
i think maybe if the players were both
under one minute or so then hans would
have decent chances because the white
king is maybe slightly more open than
its counterpart but
magnus having four minutes that feels
like enough
to convert this and we've seen it before
actually last month in the air things
masters and in the prelims between these
two uh between these two players as soon
as magnus got a material advantage he
converted it very smoothly
in the prelims it was actually similar
it was kind of a slower start and then
it just blew uh blew open the center
kind of burst into life the game but
then as soon as it calmed down again
magnus won very very smoothly and there
we go
recaptured and
look at the white knight it's such a
strong piece it stops the black rook
from coming down to the bottom board to
the first row and attacking the white
queen and king and why did it take with
the queen and not the king
that's a good question
i think maybe the king would have been
okay too but maybe i think uh magnus had
foreseen that the black rook was coming
down to the second rank anyway the white
queen would have come under fire so it's
just a timing thing um
rook was coming here anyway why not just
get the white queen out of the way first
uh instead of wasting a move and then
having to move her again anyway
yeah but yeah right now this black work
at least trying to cause some damage
attacking a couple of pawns and magnus
just bringing his queen up
okay interesting he's actually gambiting
his pawn in the corner here we've talked
about that white a2 pawn alice the apon
a couple of times already this game and
earlier hans didn't take that pawn can
he get away with capturing it now that's
the big question and wouldn't it look
quite nice for those two uh black pawns
on that side then if it's open be a
dream it would be a dream but he also
needs uh black to sorry white to trade
of queens as well okay because whilst
the queen's on the board both kings are
unsafe there's a lot of danger so i mean
the principal thing that hans is
considering right now if he captures
that pawn he concedes the sea lion and
maybe white will put a rook there and
start asking some questions yeah some
real i mean problems here possibly for
hans if he gets greedy and captures this
pawn it's the first move on my radar
it's the first thing huns will be
calculating as well if you can take a
pawn now suddenly you have three black
pawns in return for the white knight end
games might even be in your favor the
white knight will be stretched
but as ivanka mentions there's a couple
of moves here that are very tempting for
white the rook can okay he doesn't go
for it understandably the rook can slide
across attacking the black queen the
knight can move yeah also if you notice
these two pieces are on the same
diagonal white has a big threat of
checking in the center of the wood and
hitting both of those two pieces at the
same time and as you have encompassed
the white knight can move maybe to block
in the black queen hem hemetin the white
pawn can step forward maybe going for a
direct checkmate too much to calculate
there too many scary moves
i think
on this occasion greed was not good so
hans
his sense of danger was
was kind of alert there so he just moved
his king forward off that diagonal that
i mentioned and now the pawn stepping
forward which looks really scary
trying to support a queen check would
simply be met by uh queen takes pawn on
this square
and yeah or maybe even a queen check
here it's
a lot of checks for both sides to work
out right now so i mean hans has these
pawns and he has a rook on that dream
second line
so what is the star player here for
minus is it simply that knight he has or
why is the bar liking it more for minus
yeah it likes the night yeah it likes
the nicer over the two pawns that
that black has i mean that's the basic
issue at the minute and also you know
white's rook is quite good white's queen
is also quite good but it's mainly the
knight okay and if you compare the two
pawns at the moment they don't really do
too much the two pawns black has in
return for the night are these two i
guess uh one of them uh this one guards
the black king so that's a decent pawn
but this pawn while the heavy pieces are
still on the board the queens and the
rooks it's not really gonna start
advancing any time soon it will just be
captured
so it's better to have a piece in
general which is so flexible which is a
good defender covering this first rank
but also maybe an attacker later on
going towards the black king and uh yeah
i mentioned the end game is favoring
white but there are some end games
especially if this pawn in the corner
drops where the knight is not as good as
the pawns and while magnus is going for
it now he's bringing his knight he's
threatening a deadly check hitting the
black king and queen at the same time
but the knight is no longer a defender
so this is a nasty check and how is
white going to run out of this you have
to step up the board
there we go magnus running away from the
track and is he gonna continue running
for example if the rook checks the white
king do you have to step up the board
again
and wow the king the only way to find
safety is to run behind your own pieces
and the problem is the black rook cannot
really step up to create this pin now
because there's a night fork remember
check and winning the black queen and
okay this one's really heating up the
queen has come down to check the uh
check the white king and now i think
magnus is going to do the same he's
going to hide somewhere on the edge of
the board is he going to stop here or
here
really big decision it is a big decision
because there are a lot of checks on the
board so if you step forward with your
king on a light square then the queen
can come and check diagonally yeah
and uh the game continues right yeah and
if you go the other way ivanka and if
you go up the board then the rook will
come and give check and uh if the king
goes to the light square again it's a
diagonal check and this time it's even
worse
you're gonna get uh probably mated there
yeah this king is definitely gonna get
checkmated so i think his only idea okay
was to block with the knight i think
maybe he could have stepped up the board
and then blocked with the knight in this
direction uh now stepped back but okay
the move is coming really fast now
big big threat on the board the white
knight actually stepped back as a
defender and now hans is trying to line
up on the first rank a nasty check
behind the king and behind the queen
magnus has to be really careful now this
is a deadly threat he has to use this
queen to cover this square i feel maybe
this square or this square you've got
oh you've got to be careful you've got
to be very careful because if the queen
loses connection with her rook then
there will be moves like um
rick takes uh
and he has ticked under the minute
manuscripts now you did say a few
minutes ago david then that that would
be chances for hans niemann yeah
definitely chances he's done a great job
of keeping up the pace and i think i'm
not 100 sure but maybe magnus needs to
find this move dropping the queen back
maybe we can go back to the players and
see what stockfish says the top computer
suggestions here because magnus under 30
seconds he's got a narrow path to
survival and okay white does have a few
moves to survive the knight jumping
forward to the g3 square is the best
move that's really difficult though that
is difficult
dropping the queen back also good
anything else it's going to spoil the
win
it's going to be a draw okay so we see a
third move there from stockfish but
magnus doesn't play any of the top three
suggestions will we see a turnaround now
black's okay black's back in the game
black can give a check with his rook
oh suddenly the white king is
really not safe and han's still more
than four minutes on the clock he finds
a move as well he finds the best
movement look at this white king walking
out into the open
this adventure might not end well for it
though the black queen can slide across
behind the white knight suddenly from
every angle the white king is getting
attacked and that's what our hands does
and some really dangerous checks in the
air i mean is it going to be at least a
draw for hans niemann feels like uh i
think at this point magnus wants the
draw i just would love to see the
position repeat itself and he pushes a
pawn at least now he's opened up a
diagonal towards the black king so white
queen can step forward with some checks
maybe uh so now hans i think you're
right your anchor if he wants he can
maybe force a draw by stepping with the
black queen to the f2 square and white's
king is not actually going to be able to
escape the checks there's going to be a
repetition of the position but maybe
hans wants more wow and uh
two games have already finished with the
winner liam leigh winning the first game
against david navarro and dingle iran
winning the first game against joden
from forest
these uh players have 15 minutes and
then they start game number two but liam
and digni in the lead in their
quarterfinals now on the question will
magnus crossland be in the lead after
this or even haunts anyone now yeah i
mean all three results are possible
despite the computer saying 0.0
the momentum is all in black's favor
he's turned it around white has
completely lost control
white's king is so open as well but
white still has this extra night so if
he can survive the onslaught
okay this is the second time we've seen
this position we saw a check
another check
is magnus really going to play for the
win he's considering it but only 35
seconds in order to play for the win you
i'd have to go up the board with your
king which looks terrifying or you go
back and you run to the left side of the
board but
okay is he really going to go for it no
he doesn't the players bail out with a
draw
wow
what uh well i'm gonna say what a game
by hans nem